it's not always easy getting to one of
Ireland's many offshore Islands
especially when the weather is bad
but for many the trip is worth it the
Allure of Claire Island was enough to
entice native Islander Marion and her
husband Kieran to move back from New
York three years ago going from the
center of New York City to Claire Island
we definitely had some adjustments it is
um still an isolated location in the
middle of winter that's for sure but
um the positive that way the negatives
so they do
the couple's journey is a rare reversal
of a decades-long depopulation trend and
now the Irish government has stepped in
it's offering grants of up to 84 000
Euro that's around 72 000 pounds for
people to buy property on the islands
so why wouldn't you accept such a big
payment from the Irish government to
come and live somewhere like this what's
the catch
well to get your hands on one of these
sizable grants you have to commit to
buying one of these at derelict or a
vacant home of which there are all too
many here on these offshore islands and
then spend the money on a renovation and
that's often easier said than done given
the remoteness of these locations
but I don't think in its present form
that it's a
financially business owner Humphrey
doesn't think the grant will be enough
not really no everything literally out
here has more than doubled in price to
in order to organize and build and
transportation and so on 84 000 would
not be enough to do that uh in the first
place and it needs to be re-looked at
our our re-redone
access to healthcare can be an obstacle
to repopulation so Claire island has
turned to technology a pilot scheme will
see a robotic dog capable of delivering
first aid supplies to Injured hikers
drones that can deliver small items like
epipens and high-speed internet to
enable remote medical consultations
it's not easy and a lot of the Islanders
did all of the owners accept that there
is there's a limit you can't have a GP
on your doorstep immediately the more
money that goes into this kind of a
project the better and people will be
encouraged to come here the new
technology may take some getting used to
but combined with the government grants
it's hoped it will incentivize new
arrivals to join a tight-knit community
in a unique setting and help keep
Ireland's Islands alive Steven Murphy
Sky News on Claire Island